alors que la saga vous avez bien ça va
ça va je te vois faire la bise à tous
les parents d'élèves qui arrive bien
rapport particulier à ouessant way la
plupart cédés percer les copains depuis
le temps mais oui ah bon trop bien ça
fait huit ans que je suis là et en fait
on nous avait appelés donc moi je
sortais de l'iufm du désert le concours
et nos directives de trop nous avait
appelés pour nous dire qu'il y avait un
poste de libre à ouessant et que
personne n'en voulait et donc il y avait
deux choix soit quelqu'un se dévoue et
dans la promo soit on été tirées au sort
et a pas avoir réfléchi basse et
rapidement je suis venu bosser ici avec
davantage de savoir que si je voulais
rester sur le post je pouvais rester
mais si je voulais partir si j'avais pas
de pas d'obligation et donc bas depuis
aucun regret c'est que du bonheur ici
donc haut la morale et la classe des ce1
c'est fini on corrige dans une époque
les profs les médecins quittent les
honneurs au cul entre guillemets pour
aller vers les groupes du tout à fait un
choix inverse
oui j'ai fait le choix de ne pas bosser
alors des villes comme brest ou la plus
grande pour lire ici parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure je pense que dans
les écoles plus grande sur des plus
grandes villes on perd un peu peut-être
le rapport aussi proche qu'on peut avoir
avec les élèves les parents même la
mairie ici avec qui voit là je travaille
beaucoup pour tout ce qui est la gestion
de l'école et tout se passe très très
bien et moi j'aime bien justement les
petits et les petits microcosme comme ça
où tout le monde se connaît tous on se
salue du monde et bienveillant les uns
envers les autres
donc ça c'est c'est comme super
intéressant mais pour les cp on va faire
on va terminer le l'alligator sous lui
dernier épisode
et oui faut bien le terminer oui je
donnais n'a fait l'essai mais on va
faire les musiciens de brême
merci et les cm on va faire une petite
chasse aux erreurs jeu face aux erreurs
c'est un petit texte avec des fautes et
ils doivent jouer aux maîtres et
maîtresses à corriger le maximum de
fautes dans le texte sur le continent le
week-end maintenant que je suis ici
maintenant je vis ici à temps plein
enfin la plupart du temps et je rentre
pas pour faire de la musique à côté pour
des répètes ou des concerts
[Musique]
ces syndromes 80 donc c'est du punk que
jean françaix ça les fait rire parce que
du coup elles ont mis tout de l'année à
savoir c'était quoi le nom de mon groupe
donc non elle ça mais parce que ça les
intrigues aussi je le raconte d'humour
quand je pars en tournée en concert où
j'étais quelqu'un j'ai vu donc voilà
faut qu'on soit vers 11 heures au port
[Musique]
timone c'est votre maître depuis quand
c'est fait
[Musique]
voilà prof moniteur en mer sauveteurs en
mer tous ici
[Musique]
ça fait partie aussi de leur éducation
de faire de faire du bateau oui mais
c'est super important pour défendre le
savoir nager puis naviguer pour moi oui
c'est un privilège ou et c'est une
chance incomparable
après il ya d'autres endroits qui sont
forcément super sympa mais je pense que
j'ai la chance de pouvoir bosser dans un
endroit que j'apprécie énormément avec
des gens que j'apprécie énormément donc
voir un que ça c'est déjà un beau
privilège c'est pas donné à tout le
monde
non je pense que j'ai de la chance aux
plateformes arrière pas te dire que vers
cette page web c'est vrai que j'en ai
reparlé justement des anciens certains
anciens collègues de l'ofppt de cette
fameuse promo en question qui début
étaient tous ravis que je prenne le
poste c'est les a enlevés à leur enlever
des tulipiers je pense
et finalement après quand ils ont vu bas
que j'étais sacrément heureux est
simplement content d'être là bon
finalement c'était tout passionné que ça
de venir bosser ici est que dès que
j'avais fait le bon choix
à ce moment là ouais bon match à merci